I thought in first of all when I was in
your shoes I've learned a lot over
compensation over the years a lot of
surprises that I didn't expect when I
joined my first startup and hoping we're
hoping today to go through a bunch of
content when I tried to put some content
together I was lucky enough to get two
of the folks that I think know the most
of my network in compensation to join
and I think it'd be great if you guys
could just tell a little bit about your
backgrounds first hi I'm Tim Wenzel and
I'm currently VP of HR at a startup
called talk box in San Francisco prior
to that I was VP of HR for Tesla Motors
the electric car company and then prior
to that I was director of staffing at
PayPal so I joined the first recruiter
there back in 2000 and sort of grew the
staffing organization as the company
scaled and when someone when SAR reached
out to me about this I thought you know
I'd love to come talk but I'm really
more of a recruiter than a compensation
expert I am fascinated by the whole art
and science of compensation but I was a
little bit incentive intimidated to come
as you know as an expert so Marlowe is
probably the most brilliant comp person
that I knew so I thought he could come
and actually deliver some content that
was that was more more valuable that I
could bring so but I'm happy to be here
I'm Marlo Rondo nee-nee-nee but that's a
common mistake in my name I've been
getting that a lot and I most recently
was the VP of HR at Stanford Corporation
I've last I'm about to join a clinical
research company kind of a return of my
misspent youth and actuarial science of
all things and computer science in terms
of my background and education Sanchar
is one of many companies are really
struggling in the downturn so we had to
quickly move production to China and try
to live on our cash because the I feel
market just got noticed is not good is
that fair so by way of compensation
actually worked with the Roger
organization
if any of you have heard of them they
sort of have the premier benchmark
salary survey for high tech and all the
companies get every think of our members
of that so that's kind of where the
compensation experience came from and
then also the real-life experience and
being a VP of HR I've also been through
a couple of startups during the Internet
boom first one you made a lot of money
and sold ourselves to a competitor and
then we lost it all in the next one
because we thought we were smart not
lucky so that's a little bit about me so
afraid so just we put together a quick
deck I'm hoping it'll take us about 30
minutes to get through it if you have
burning questions feel free to raise
your hand during the panel we'd love to
address your question otherwise let's
try and save it to the end because we're
gonna try and cover a lot including
these things here to keep some focus to
the conversation though we're not going
to talk about we're going to try and
focus this conversation to compensation
and accepting an offer in a venture back
startup if you guys are interested in
being a founder figuring out founder
compensation partnerships other things
we can potentially set up another time
to do that or every answer your
questions at the end but with that I
thought we'd start today with just some
really basic questions that I know I had
when I graduated from the GSB and will
sort of run this in a panel type format
so I guess Tim and Marlowe if it's my
first job coming out of a corporation or
the GSB should I expect a big pay cut to
join a venture-backed startup so the
short answer is it depends I would say
generally speaking it's less common that
I think a lot of people think to have to
take a significant pay cut I'd say on
base pay it's generally you're going to
find that decently funded startups are
going to be competitive on base pay
relative to large corporations or sort
of non technology type companies where
you're going to see the difference I
think is that most venture backed
companies don't offer a bonus plan so
you're generally trading some cash in
the form of a bonus for upside on the
equity so the times where I've seen
people have to take a base pay
that is generally when they're working
for a big company and happened to be
more toward 75th percentile on cash or
if they're coming out of you know an
investment bank or in venture capital
world then you know the comp model is
different in those in those
organizations so you might see you know
a decent pay cut if you're sort of
killing it on the cash but in the
corporate technology world you know
there's not going to be generally a
significant pay cut if you want to do
yeah I know that that fits I do to comp
studies for my board that's ant were and
we were sitting at the 50th percentile
and this was across large and small
companies so we were finding that an
engineer or certain roles at a at a mid
state mid-level startup it was very
similar to even large companies that we
were competing for talent for so so yeah
and base pay usually right in there and
you're definitely gonna be giving up
stuff on incentive compensation other
cash so great and benefits generally are
a little less generous and venture back
and most venture-backed startups so next
question when you get an offer
sometimes these offers can be pretty
scary you have language like at will and
people don't always react well to that
what should folks expect to see in an
offer from a startup yeah well first off
that will my labor attorney wouldn't
want me to say this but it's it's not
they can't just fire you for any for any
reason whatsoever so somebody walks in
and says you're out of here you're at
will there's still rules to follow so
you know protect yourselves on that
regard but generally the letter is going
to be a combination of a couple of
things it's as clearly going to state
your usually your title nice to know
what that is and your direct report
clearly your compensation and your
eligibility for other benefits
there'll be general stuff about your
stock option your grant usually that's
the grant itself has not approved till
the next board meeting but you'll have
the basic information there and there'll
be a number of things again about at
will you're usually signing up for a
mandatory arbitration and the event of
any conflict there if any of you are not
US citizens
there'll be stipulations in there that
you need to be
approved to work in the US if there's
visa issues you need to state state
those kind of things right up front so
that they can handle the management of
the transfer of your visa or even help
you with h-1b find out if they'll pay
for it and or if you leave within a
certain amount of time whether they will
charge you for the 10 grand is going to
take to get you of proper properly visa
and then there's also the famous some
form of a proprietary information and
that an inventions agreement it's not
really a non-compete but it's really
just talking about drawing the
boundaries around the intellectual
property that's going to be owned by the
company versus yours and so if you have
you know prior inventions and things of
that nature that's the vehicle through
which you want to disclose all that so
that you're not you know giving it up
something that really is yours but also
defining the boundaries of what belongs
to the company that you're going to join
anything else basically it that's great
so I started my career in investment
banking where folks are very focused on
their annual bonus as I'm sure you guys
know in startups do people get bonuses
who gets bonuses what should people
expect I found that as I said earlier in
at least pre-revenue pre profit
venture-backed startups bonuses are
going to be pretty rare usually you kind
of try to establish milestones that the
exact team level in terms of when it
makes sense to move the comp in that
direction and generally the model is as
you know as you approach IPO or after
your public there tends to be a little
less upside on the on the equity so that
tends to be a good time and if your
business is doing well that usually is
roughly in the same ballpark as the time
where your revenue starting to grow and
hopefully you're on a nice track toward
profitability so like at PayPal for
example we had no bonus until until eBay
bought us basically and then we sort of
slowly
adopted their about this program so I
think it's generally not a good idea to
offer bonuses when you're not profitable
because you want everyone you know
you're everyone's gonna be shareholders
you want everyone to kind of have the
same sort of motivation and and as
everyone tries to get to a profitability
and then once you hit that milestone
then I think it makes sense to start
implementing some sort of bonus
structure but I mean that may be
oversimplifying the issue because
obviously every business is different
but yeah I think that works for a lot of
roles for those of you guys thinking of
going into sales there are different
beasts yeah and most to sell the set of
plans that I've seen lately are usually
up to an additional 50 percent but you
tend not to see bonuses really in two
categories I do see them a lot for a VP
level and above
I also especially for more mature
startups will also see some various
forms of development incentive plans
we're living in our R&D team tasked with
certain things and but but generally
speaking yeah not not going to see a lot
of annual bonuses it is common practice
for an annual salary focal or or at
anniversary performance reviews mayor
budgets have been kind of been a three
to four percent range the overall budget
now obviously some people get a zero and
some people get 20 but there's generally
some commitment to to that practice
you're going to see a lot of variance on
how well they do it most startups are
just really suck at you know this stuff
in terms of just management in general
so you'll be walking into a lot of
companies that they just don't think
about those things they don't think
about organization they don't think
about the problems of performance even
though you have really brilliant people
in the room so you even see a lot of bad
management and so you'll have to find
you know the Grace and the metal to to
deal with the circumstances and try to
help your organization thrive no matter
what so what's great and what I'm sorry
when we're working on the options
practices I'd say they do vary widely
again depending on how how mature the
the management of the the company is but
I'd say it is you know it's not it's
usually my recommendation to couple the
annual performance review process with
at least a look at both base pay and a
refresh Grant
opportunity and then you try and make
those based on performance so if top
performers you should in my opinion
constantly be refreshing their stock on
an annual basis and then you know some
companies end up doing the twice a year
or some companies don't do it at all and
then they realize wait a minute this top
performer is sort of about two best out
of their new-hire grant let's rush and
try and make it up but I like to try and
make it an annual review process across
all company that way you can compare
your entire and you can sort of racks
tank your performers and then and then
sort of make sure you're you're taking
care of your top performers first
correct so this is one of the probably
most common questions everyone has is
you have an offer is it a good offer how
much would you expect to get paid coming
out of the GSB we're gonna address this
again and later in the presentation as
well I'll give you some resources where
you can find some really granular data
but but at a high level if you're a
newly minted MBA what do you get paid so
I'm just gonna throw out a ballpark
I haven't actually hired newly minted
MBAs for the last year so my my data
points may be slightly outdated but 85
to 125 sort of a wide range but that's
sort of what what I saw the last time I
was sort of recruiting yeah and to cut
it maybe cut it a little bit depending
upon what you would qualify for by
virtue of you know your prior experience
and all that more company more also not
companies have a very excessive leveling
and so the big buckets are like senior
manager director usually a couple of
levels of director and then VP level so
when you're kind of looking at those you
know comp ranges you're looking at the
senior manager level kind of in the 90
to 100 range directors are probably in
the 110 up to 150 for a director two
levels and then a VP level is sort of
140 to 190 and you're going to see more
of that and especially in more mature
startups and so those are kind of the
general you know the general guidelines
and some of that is going to be a
function of again prior experience and
what you bring to the table just being
an MBA certainly from Stanford is a
non-trivial benefit but a lot of the
high tech startups are going to
we'll be interesting as you discover how
how they view you and you know take
notes and you know sell yourself in the
right way to secure you know over the
best compensation you can get they
actually don't know a lot of the time
what you used to make and then it
becomes as jockey and exercise of you
know what else they want to pay you so
you're gonna you're going to be
interviewed by people that are probably
is it will informed as you might be in
some levels that I mean to generate
anyone at various startups but they're
often does really not experienced and
and so when I was approving offers it
was pretty hysterical what they would
propose and why and I usually had to
kind of bring him back to what practice
was and what the company's compensation
goals were so people good sense of humor
about it I think it's probably obvious
to many that you're not gonna get rich
off salaries and startups adventure back
startup so what we thought we would do
is just spend a few minutes going
through some basics in options and and
we'll go through some details and then
we'll get into some math of how you
should think about an option offer and
how you actually get rich with options
Marla do you want to take a quiz this is
just kind of a kind of a check point
because I don't know in the room who's
had experience with options before or
not so kind of a quick little quiz the
kind of jog your own thoughts about gee
I need to know that or I don't know that
so I'm not going to get really detailed
but I'm just going to click through a
few questions and and give the answers
and and hopefully it'll be a help for
areas that you may need to study is you
kind of look into your your next career
move so how do I go forward okay an
option is in the money if it's vested
and therefore exercisable its price is
less than the stocks market value or the
price is greater than the stocks market
value but you want to throw out an
answer a B or C
okay room says be okay good yeah in the
money when the price is less in the
stocks market value so unfortunately
right now sorry I'm if you've done the
math yet but I'm my gut tells me that
anybody they got a grant in the last two
years or more is underwater right now so
so in some respects it like if you go to
work for a company that's already public
you're probably going to get a you know
some basement prices on you know on
stock so you might there might be some
real benefits there but but yeah and the
money is good but that's not what's
going on right now non qualified stock
options you'll get this sort of issue of
NSO's versus is OS and sign of stock
options but taxes are triggered when the
options are granted when the options are
exercised when the stock is sold or both
B and C anybody want to swag that one
yeah it's a B and C so if if you if you
are in an association usually that's a
value point you're going to be granted
is those but if the value blows 100,000
then it becomes an NSO and therefore the
attached rules change but generally if
they order income tax on the spread and
and again as you you're going to learn
all this if you haven't but when you I
learned all this when I first actually
received a grant for the first time I've
had a review option plan and all that
and so you're going to be able to teach
this yourself just by virtue of being a
recipient of stuff along so stock
options themselves they allow you to buy
certain number of shares a preset price
is on a timeframe require you to buy a
or prohibit you from buying any stock in
your plan
yeah preset price so you get the echo
grant the number of shares and the
strike for exercise price and usually
you're going to see plans that have a
10-year expiration there immediately
exercisable whether they're best it or
not and and that's pretty typical now
there's not a lot of variance nowadays
and in these plans
so within Sano stock options taxes are
triggered when the options are granted
when the options are exercised when the
stock is sold sorry depends
anyway um typically it depends so
depending on how you've actually done
the exercise so again if you're if you
have stock options you may have a
decision to make when do I exercise why
really acts do I wait and so just it's
just a reminder that's gonna be one of
the issues that there are tax
implications so my company santoor if I
when I exercised on a grant I had a
cough up seventy five thousand dollars
you know for the shares and then I got a
tax bill on the spread and so I mean not
a pretty big deal and so when you make
that exercise you know make sure you
know what you get into so I think also
just in our discussion Marlo had a great
point when we were preparing for this
that most companies are just gonna tell
you to refer to your tax advisor around
these issues the companies are not set
out to be helpful to you guys and
figuring out how to manage your options
and so you really should there are
different tax implications here you
should absolutely spend the time and
talk to your tax consultant okay we're
stock options we granted it discounts in
our market price non qualified incentive
stock options are both
that's a discount and some I ask those
are greater equal to the stocks market
value NS those are the ones that could
be granted at a discount and again
depending upon where you're at in the
company the types of grants that you're
going to get there are their
implications for NSO's they also have
the transferability which you know can
be nice in certain situations okay Tim
can answer this one for us this prude
necrotize your options early sorry I
went too fast but anyway this is 10%
rule for me when I was early in my
career I didn't care if I had 50 or 75
percent in stock but overall the the
real issue is is part of your own
portfolio management and in what other
assets you have I think at your stage I
still overly you know invested in
certain things and because I'm kind of
stupid that way but in with regard to
the stock itself how do you feel about
the company how the prospects good or
bad and what's your own sort of risk
tolerance I don't mind I actually kind
of like gambling so I might be a little
bit more willing to have a larger
percentage of my total portfolio vested
in my company's stock it's probably not
the smartest thing in the world so it's
you know more risk you could get more
hurt or you could get richer so you kind
of think about what your risk tolerance
is and then and then in addition to that
how much confidence do you have in your
company's prospects and then make a
decision yeah
or I'm sorry I mean I think this applies
to both private and publicly traded
companies obviously with a public
company you know what the value is so
you're a little bit you have a better
get more information and it's liquid so
it's a little bit different but I would
say that if if it's a private company
and you know you're you know like let's
say let's say the strike price is
relatively high and you have to actually
shell out you know a fair amount of cash
to you know to invest in the company's
stock and it's not liquid and maybe your
base pay isn't huge and there's no bonus
you know all of those things lend itself
to having more skin in the game versus a
publicly traded company you know you can
sell and I'd suggest if you if you are
at a public traded company you have
stock options I'm a fan of selling at
regular intervals so you know once there
is an exit I wouldn't personally suggest
that you hold on to the stock too long I
had a lot of friends that did that at
PayPal and sort of got got smoked by it
because you know the stock took a pretty
big dive like around oh five I think so
so I mean there's sort of a ton of
information that we could go on and on
about here but I don't know if that
answers your question
is there another question over here
just judgment but one of the things that
you consider before starting to get that
in the end we're gonna try and focus is
really on compensation not not judgment
of what how do you pick a start up I
think that's probably just a very
different conversation well we want to
address it but let's do it later
yeah so just to kind of wrap up the
stock really quickly those are some of
the issues that you'll be facing if
you're gonna have to copy so bottom line
you fighting to get is OS when you're
trying to start up boards are normally
setting the guidelines for what you can
get so there's some variability there
but they're not a ton of variability
usually immediately exercise a little
vest over four years first year as a
cliff of zero percent first year you're
25% invested must be thereafter and then
a weari talked about follow-on grants
and the big thing you know speaking of
judgment is the valuation of these
things is really tricky because you're
basically going to be told what the
amount of shares are what percentage
about standing it is and a strike price
and not a lot else and you can use all
kinds of models on the web to figure out
what they might be worth and it's very
theoretical so you are in fact making a
decision about what you feel about the
prospects of the company so and yes
please
yeah it goes why strike was the current
valuation so yep if they done I you got
a problem all right
good question
so just a couple few more quick
questions for those of you that will be
disappointed with your initial option
grant the obvious question is can you
get more yeah so I touched on this a
little bit earlier the answer is its
varies widely I would suggest that if
you join a company you're there for you
know over a year and you feel like
you're performing at a really sort of
high level I'd ask the question if
there's you know there's not a mature
performance management process in place
where you actually sit down and review
by your manager a lot of managers aren't
good at making it a priority so you may
have to make sure they have their
one-on-ones and make sure you're having
career discussions with your manager ask
for feedback if they're not giving it to
you if the feedback is positive and
they're don't be afraid to say hey know
can I can we talk about what it takes to
get another Refresh grant question so
asking what the process is for what the
opportunities might look like in the
future for refresh grants another
question that's generally going to be a
policy of the company and you might get
an answer in an unstructured environment
that says yeah we can talk about that or
the other extreme is yes it happens on
June 1st every year company-wide
and we you know we do a performance
review and we have ranges you know that
that's you know it tends to sort of when
you get bigger they tend to hire HR
people that have done this stuff before
and then you start seeing it and in the
less structured so in those companies
it's not as much of an issue because
it's not something that's really going
to be pre negotiable because it's gonna
be based on performance if it's early
stage and sort of wild-west you know
small company it's good to ask the
question and then have follow-on
discussions as you're as you're going
through your time with the company
no actually related questions I'd be
astonished at what people don't ask and
so I kind of tease them a little bit
inside don't you want to know this so
what one caution here is if you're going
to work for a later stage startup a lot
of these companies you know santoor was
hoping to do an IPO and I was seven and
decided to defer it then the IPO market
kind of petered out well they were
expecting you know a payday and I know
actually were running out of stock and
many mature startups you know how many
shares are even eligible to grant now I
guess good news bad news is they've been
tons of layoffs so they probably got a
lot of shares back but but for mature
startups you know you want to ask a few
more those questions about about
valuation and their plans and also how
many shares are available for grant
because I have seen a lot of again
companies that we're expecting to go
public they're now five years six years
seven years into it and they're they're
running out of shares which means if
they're going to grant more there's more
dilution while you wait for the market
to get better so great do this one
quickly I think it is a surprise for
some folks that they have to buy shares
right right what happens when you leave
if you get fired so if you if you have
if you've hit your usually there's a
one-year cliff on your options so if you
haven't hit your one-year and you did
early exercise you just get your check
you get your money back so companies
generally have a 90 day window to
exercise their right to buy back and in
almost every scenario that I've seen the
company actually does that because
they'd be effectively giving you four
years worth of stock otherwise the only
scenario where that might happen would
be where if the company is going through
bankruptcy you're about to fold and they
just don't have to actually do that but
it's a that's pretty rare yeah but
bottom line is you can exercise on your
vest chairs and and keep them so that's
usually the plan and again if you early
exercise and that's this year's will be
bought back by the company you got a
check
yeah I think that one surprised that
I've seen time and time again as folks
who have a decent size option grant and
then they leave a company and they have
30 days in some cases 90 days and others
to write a pretty big check if they have
an exercise already and then they're
going through this exercise to decide
what to do it can be quite quite painful
right when you get the grant you know
you're not writing a check so there's
something called an ACD election which
is the right to exercise your shares
early so even though you have invested
them you can most companies offer you
the right to buy all four years worth of
your shares upfront and there's some tax
benefits to doing that so that's what it
relates to is buying back the investment
shares yeah so if you're exercised on
ten thousand and you're only halfway
through they're gonna buy back five
thousand so in the oppor letter what are
the key questions you need to ask to
evaluate an option
grant many shares are there outstanding
it's really about percentage of the
company so the actual number of shares
doesn't really matter because you know
if the company has a billion shares
outstanding and they're offering you
100,000 shares a hundred thousand sounds
like a pretty good number but if you do
the math it's actually not and you
should be aware that if you don't
already know this that as companies get
closer to the IPO they look at how many
shares are outstanding what their target
IPO price is going to be and then
they'll adjust the number of shares
outstanding based on that so I paid pal
for example we did a four for one weaver
split so you had a hundred thousand
shares that new-hire all of a sudden you
had twenty five thousand shares before
the IPO and some employees freaked out
they said wait a minute the company's
stealing from me when that's not
actually true you're just just division
and it's so changing so again just the
percentage of the company's the main
thing to think about
great we thought we'd just give you one
quick example of how you actually get
rich with options
these are the basics you're gonna get a
grant of some number of shares in this
case 50,000 options with an exercise
price of $0.10 you're gonna find out how
many shares are fully outstanding which
is going to give you an ownership number
and you have to make some assumption
around how your ownership will get
diluted over time and that can be
related to private financing or a public
financing and then you need an
assumption around the exit I think the
interesting thing here is there's very
few things here that are in your control
the exit number the dilution over time
etc really are not things you can
control you can just build a sensitivity
model to do that but ultimately you want
to know how do you make lots of money
and it really comes down to the final
exit value either at an IPO or a sale so
I think what's interesting here is if
you look on a pretty small grant at a
billion dollar exit the gross proceeds
would be about 3.8 million dollars in
this example if you just want to put
that in context you know Google which is
probably the best venture investment in
history the United speak was trading at
a 250 billion dollar market cap so you
can run the math or with some of your
friends who are early employees that
Google might be worth and I think the
other real issue here is you're going to
hear this I think from a lot of your
professors in start-up land it's it's
much more important that you pick the
right company than picking a company as
you go through evaluating which startup
to join in and especially in this
environment you know historically I
think when we look at the data at
Charles River ventures there's really
only been a handful of billion-dollar
exits every year which to go back is
that 3.8 million dollar payout for a
newly minted MBA and if you exclude the
dot-com days and then you think about
the current environment you can get
pretty depressed pretty quickly about
you know how what your chances are of
seeing you know I
you pay out from options if we look
today at you know from an IPO visibility
window I'd say no one has visibility
into when the IPO window is going to
come back from a named M&A perspective
you know stocks are depressed from
acquirers there's not a lot of companies
sitting on tons of cash and so you know
if you ask me for my perspective I think
it's much more likely we'll see exits in
the hundred million to five hundred
million dollar range or even smaller
over the next few years if you were
looking for a payout based on your
equity sometime soon but that being said
that you know we're still believers that
you know there are a handful of
companies every year that are huge
outcomes and you know Marlowe had a
great point which was I think prior to
the boom there were a handful of
companies in Silicon Valley that created
a lot of the wealth out of options for
folks
I think the boom was a bit of an anomaly
and my guess is we're going to be we're
going to move back to that type of
distribution of payouts at least over
the next foreseeable future so I'd
encourage you to really think hard about
the company you pick which can be
frustrating when you really are focused
on the role you want to play and
unfortunately I guess one mantra that I
often use is it's actually sometimes
more important have the wrong role with
the right company than the right role at
the wrong company
there are thousands and thousands of
venture backed startups in Silicon
Valley and just a handful are gonna get
to that billion dollar exit but with
that I guess I'm curious if anyone is
hiring and I'm glad to say the Tim's
actually here at the Stanford job fair
so he has some perspective if it weighs
a whopping company that's hiring but if
you're an MBA or any startup hiring what
can folks expect to see in this
environment yeah you know obviously the
activities much softer than it was a
year ago to say the least
but I'm finding that there's a it's
actually still a relatively competitive
market now personally I'm really focused
on hiring engineers right now but I am
still running into multiple offer
situations for sort of the cream of the
crop engineers you know I I've talked to
some you know
some of my friends who are in MBA
programs and you know I'm finding that
there are still opportunities you just
have to think about it a little bit
differently at just ours point think
more about how interesting the
businesses and you know how annoying or
not the people are that you'll be
working with and because you know you're
gonna spend so much time you know with
them over the next couple years so it's
you know it's the reality is the the
billion dollar plus exits are it's a
very small percentage of the outcomes so
you know I would encourage you to try
and say optimistic but I think if you
definitely work on your network you know
ask your smartest friends what they're
doing and to you guys all know this
stuff but I've I found that most people
that are really well networked actually
don't have to do don't have to apply
once you have some experience don't have
to spend a lot of time on job boards and
things like that and as Stanford MBAs I
know you guys are big on networking so
that's usually the best way to identify
opportunities especially in the venture
world because a lot of jobs don't
necessarily even even advertise that's
great so if you do get one of these jobs
since we have the benefits if you guys
have hired so many people you know
what's fair game what is anything
negotiable in this environment you have
any leverage as a recent MBA so I
wouldn't say that everything is
negotiable in my opinion and I think on
the details Marlo and I have I think we
agree on most of stuff but some of the
things that we don't necessarily see eye
to eye on for example time off like I
might I might not suggest that you asked
to negotiate your paid time off package
in most cases unless if it's a really
early-stage company and they don't know
what they're doing but if you're offered
something reasonable like three weeks
vacation in most cases I wouldn't I
wouldn't suggest negotiating that you
know the things to think about
negotiating would be face pay and
options in the venture world and you
know I'd say try and be reasonable and
open when you're negotiating you know
some of the things that are my personal
sort of hot buttons are when when the
candidate doesn't want to tell me what
they've been
or you know if they're not willing to at
least at a high level talk about the
other companies they're talking to I
like it to be an open discussion you
know that I can explain to them how we
look at compensation you know sort of
looking at internal comparisons looking
at the market data and coming up with
something that's reasonable and then I'd
say try to negotiate in my opinion is
negotiate once and try and get to a
reasonable place candidates that try and
negotiate two and three times it tends
to start you start burning through some
political capital and it can kind of set
your job off to the on the wrong foot in
my in my experience yeah so the benefits
package in in my experience is now I've
never really negotiated on things like
401k or medical plans that's all sort of
standard based on company policy I don't
know have you seen something different
you know not there my difference on a
time off for example is I saw four if I
if I was getting squeezed on
compensation because I'm hitting my
budget for a position I would actually
offer an additional week so normally if
you come in new to a company I think
it's really dumb but for some reason
time off is based on years of service
which has a professional that makes no
sense to me and I'm Elizabeth argument
four years of yellow in one day it just
is really daft and people that are real
professionals regardless of vacation
they work and they do the job and so
just irritating to me that they have
these schedules based on service so I
would regularly offer people that are
really wanted I would put them at the
tier so rather than easily if like zero
three years three weeks you know four to
six years you know four weeks I would
just kind of bump them up a tier and
give them an additional weeks vacation
and as for an inducement and then I've
also been asked and I was I was very
happy to have that conversation with
that with people especially that I
really wanted to get on board but yeah
and health and welfare and all that 401
K that not a lot of match is actually
think for an early-stage company it's a
poor investment even though I think it's
an amazing employee benefit that I
encourage and put in place once it's
company can't afford it health and
welfare benefits are there generally
good they're a lot richer than then you
might think they're there not many
bare-bones packages especially once the
company gets going and I usually
contributions are actually pretty low
the last survey idea they were actually
quite a bit lower than war mature
companies that we looked at so but it's
something worth asking by the way when
you're in an offer is like how much out
of pocket because you want to think of
your total pay and one of these
out-of-pocket things can can actually
change with the total pay package is if
you're having a cough up like wish if
you have a family a thousand dollars a
month for family coverage something like
that so that's great so we're running I
think three minutes four minutes over
but this is our last prepared slider
then we'll open up the open up for Q&A I
think the interesting thing that's
happened really in at least in my view
in the past three years with social
media and people contributing data to
the web is what's happened in the salary
space specifically and there's a few
companies that I just wanted to refer to
you guys you know we the ranges that we
put out there of the 80 to 120 K we
actually checked across a whole bunch of
companies but if you wanted to know you
know what does a product manager at
Google make or at Facebook or there's a
number of companies out there that that
have some of this data it's company
specific within the startup world which
which really was hard to get at before
short of going to a Radford or finding
access to a database but you can also
get reviews and other really interesting
inside information that employees have
posted now it's user generated so in
many cases they may be lying but you can
take that you know for what it's worth
and then I'd encourage you guys to
really talk to this you know CES and CMC
if you have more questions around this
they've got just a great network that
have seen a lot of things over the years
so
hence obviously on the roll but I found
in so I'm in sort of the post be round
you know 25 employees for most most of
our roles that would require an MBA
we're probably looking at anywhere from
0.25 percent of the company to one
percent the 1% would be probably for
someone more senior than a newly minted
MBA probably be someone you know five
years out but enough that gives you a
wide range and then as you get to a more
mature
late stage startup you know the
percentages are really going to go down
because you're getting a smaller piece
of a more valuable pie
yeah that's an interesting question and
something that sparks a lot of debate
amongst you know the HR community and
leaders everywhere my experience is it
it comes down to the leadership of the
company and the culture that you're
creating that's the number one sort of
thing that can help with attrition I'm a
little less focused on sort of over the
top you know benefits and you know like
we do free food at top box but I don't
think most people are deciding to join
the company because of that but when you
start getting crazy with you know
haircuts and on-site dental and all that
stuff you know I think it's fine if
you're if you're at a point we have so
much cash you can offer some of that but
I think in the last few years we've seen
some companies take that a little too
far in my opinion I mean you know a lot
of a lot of people that I've talked to
that I've either hire their we tried to
recruit out of Google for example you
gain 15 pounds on the free food the
first three months that's kind of common
knowledge and I'd rather I don't need to
put on any more way through this target
that's like okay it's purple it's a
discussion a lot gets put down on paper
and then okay so your options gonna get
to the board and they'll be approved by
the board at the point X you know in the
future I'm feeling a bit insecure about
what is gonna happen why he's gonna get
rid of that paper and if we have a
strike price and then if you leave when
you have some options invested that you
want to exercise
for those I'm encouraging not to get too
worried about when your options will be
actually approved unless you're dealing
with someone that you don't trust I
think usually you have a certain level
of trust yeah but generally it your
options will be approved at the next
board meeting most companies do monthly
board meetings so usually happens within
you know 30 days of your start date but
you're still a year away from having
hitting your cliff anyway and it's a
longer-term thing so you don't
necessarily need to rush into you know
exercising your options or getting your
stock paperwork you know unless you
think there's something shady going on
at the company in which case you
probably shouldn't yeah you get an
option agreement I've signed board
approved you're in the board minutes
when the grant has actually made the
buyback situation they can't buy back
them all if you look at most equity
plans I haven't seen one otherwise if
you have unvested shares that you had
purchased in an early exercise and
they're not vested they're not yours the
company buys them back they're not
buying back the shares they're not back
the best insurance right yeah so there's
a some for some senior executives
they're getting really big blocks you
know like a you know some star CEO that
was granted 5% there'll be all kinds of
restrictions and reap you know
repurchase rights and right of first
refusal and all that because you don't
want to have you know 10 million shares
or something you know not really working
for the company at some point so that's
a different scenario sure the same time
first years because you touch very very
briefly on summer internship sort of
salary ranges and if there's you know
any chance of options granted for this
if you choose to work there after
graduation just sort of the summer
experience I guess yeah
so my experience hiring interns is and
again it's sort of all over the map
depending on the maturity of the company
but you know at at PayPal before we were
public you know we offered fairly small
compact and it was strictly cash at the
time so if I recall correctly it was
probably somewhere the prorated 60k ish
annualized and then after the I position
by eBay we tended to be a little bit
more sort of trying to be aligned with
what you might actually see out of your
second year in a full-time role so you
know 80 to 90 can you alized
I don't think I've ever seen a situation
where you're actually getting getting
equity as an intern have you seen that
at all
you know no I mean at least the state of
California there's there's I don't think
you can even do an unpaid internship
anymore because of the way the labor
wage and hour laws work so I mean the
good news is that people are doing
internships or their pain just because
the not hath not paying somebody is just
a nightmare in this state now but but
yeah I've never really seen an option
grants to entrance just agent
so you trying to relate the refresh
range to the new higher range so you
seen typically 25 to 50% of the the new
higher range is common if it's an annual
refresh so it sounds that right yeah I
think also just given the exit
environment if you assume that the
company is likely not going to exit in
four years four key employees they're
also adding more equity every year so
that at the end of four years people
don't just walk
they're not and for a private company
they're not really linked you know tend
not to see them blink so they'll be your
base pay again generally it's coming in
at 50th percentile it just tends to be
reasonably competitive even on startup I
unless we're talking you know really
early stage or you might be working for
nothing for a while at very little and
and the options are really a function of
the rules that we talked about their
baby based upon certain levels and then
subsequent ones based upon performance
could be yeah we do rehabs
a lot before IP how to kind of fix the
mistakes you know terms of who owns what
when we're only doing it you know with
public companies you will get especially
at executive levels for the director and
above you start to see they want a
certain amount of shares outstanding as
a multiple of pay and that's where you
see this this link so certain executive
positions they're going to be granting
based upon certain value you know 2x pay
every year you know you know two three
four and five x pay for a certain
executives but that's kind of helpful
that that's what it does in fact related
to compensation you also with in
negotiating an offer flying folks often
trade off salary for more equity correct
those propose that to you other yeah I
mean I think in an earlier stage
companies you'll probably more commonly
find companies who are willing to give
these sort of a sliding scale and I used
to do that my first couple years of
PayPal I'd kind of give candidates three
different packages to choose from
depending on their risk tolerance and I
might have given them a maybe a 10k
spread on cash with corresponding option
grants that are sort of tiered so lower
cash higher equity or vice-versa
and then as as you get more mature it's
harder to do that you know after the
eBay acquisition you know you kind of
couldn't be quite as creative yeah in
this market the I would have candidates
asked me how much cash do we have you
know can we pay the salary
people ask me negotiating more for cash
of that equity people don't want equity
or
over the last year for the surprise
Sokka wait okay so if your strike price
is ten cents you're gonna get you're
gonna get ten cents to share back so
there's not gonna be a difference that
makes sense because you actually haven't
earned those those shares yet so it's
just sort of reconciling back those
shares to the pet so if you're the
entrepreneur you're the employer and
someone works for you for a year you
fire them let's say they had a hundred
thousand shares over four years you get
to buy back seventy five thousand shares
so at seventy-five thousand shares times
the strike price from it's ten cents you
just do the math if they've exercised if
they've exercised right if they have an
exercise that's not an issue because
there hasn't been any price of sin to
fight with sale
ten cents this is the section this
direct price of auxin so they have a
fool
the exit for Jeremiah
they said they'd sell their restitch
chairs at almost market price is great
when you say sell so you talk about it
at exit yeah that's right if it's a if
it's a public company you sell at the
market price it's an acquisition the
market prices to negotiate with in the
deal you have a concept of acceleration
in let's say an exit so if I've only
bested let's say a year 25 percent of
the hundred thousand shares and then
there's an MA or an IPO there may be in
my offer letter or in the option grant
some language around acceleration around
an exit so in the case of change in
control you may see a a 25 percent
acceleration we had that at PayPal so if
you were one year vested deal happens
all of a sudden you'd be 50 percent
vested overnight I my I believe Milo
correct me if I'm wrong I think that
sort of practice is becoming less common
at least firms of people I've talked to
and said well the B C's you know it's a
real sweethearts but they don't they
don't like it they don't like the double
trigger is an accelerated vest and you
tend to only see it at certain executive
positions I have not seen a broad you
know change of control type of
accelerated best for for all people so
okay let me take one last question and
then we'll just be around afterwards for
those of you guys don't want to keep
talking
so it's shifted in the last couple years
I've seen especially in the chair
companies its instead of you know base
pay plus bonus plus options
now the most common practice is base
play plus bonus plus a lower amount of
options and RS use so I think the the
logic behind that is that when the stock
goes down you at least have some value
that you're accruing over time with RS
use versus explain what RFU's ors use is
a restricted stock basically you're
instead of an option which is a right to
purchase and RSU is the company is
actually giving you shares so it'll be a
much lower number of shares because
there's no strike price there's no
you're not showing out cash so it's a
little bit less risky for you less
upside but yeah that's a good question
something we didn't really cover here is
that that is shifting RFC's are becoming
much more common practice especially in
in public companies some of that stuff
to protect against repricing z' were
always hated by institutional
shareholders but accepted as some
although by boards and all that because
you know things were going up up up but
there's this that that practice not a
lot of appetite for it so I've been sort
of designing around that fact and it's a
way to deliver value to employees
consistently over over a period of time
and using those design strategies to you
know to help just managers total comp
you know package and remove some of the
you know slings and arrows of things we
can't control in the market so I just
wanted to quickly try to address your
question earlier about how to pick a
company that's gonna be suited in 30
seconds of I don't know if there's
anyone that's an expert in that I mean
that you can talk to venture capitalists
that have you know that spend their time
that X pursuing this and they still have
mixed results
you know when YouTube first started I
personally didn't see the potential
there I actually tried to talk Steve
Chen out of not leading PayPal to go
work full-time at YouTube so I I don't
know if there's I think you have to kind
of trust your gut your intuition do your
analysis of the market etc
I don't know that I don't another you
talk about more afterwards to talk to
SAR if you're trying to evaluate a
business these guys are super busy so if
you guys could just give me
you